quand on dort tranquille dans les
banlieues dortoirs voit les étoiles
noires descendre suède
ils n'étaient pas nés dans les années
soixante dix et pourtant ces étudiants
ont choisi de reprendre sur scène
starmania l'opéra rock de luc plamondon
et michel berger
je suis une fan inconditionnelle de
michel berger et france gall et je sais
pas je pense que c'était un coup de
foudre et les couteaux dont les explique
pas je les personnaliser parce qu'on a
pris la version la deuxième version donc
celle de 89 mais j'ai mis des des
chansons la version de 78 auditions en
septembre répétitions chaque semaine un
quotidien partagé entre cours et comédie
musicale ils sont tous étudiants à
l'université versailles saint quentin
c'était très intensif il fallait bien
connaître bien connaître les chansons
après c'est surtout le rô le joué le
personnage qui est un peu compliqué
surtout quand on va se mettre dans la
peau d'un homme sac c'est pas facile
mais après à force de travail et à
fournir des efforts toul
c'est quelque chose que je ne connais
pas du tout et où je peux davantage me
perfectionner
mais ça me plaît bien c'est je trouve ça
amusant il ya 40 ans starmania lancé les
carrières de france gall et daniel
balavoine
ces étudiants connaîtront eux leur
première celle de 9 décembre
ziggy johnny rockfort et crystal n'ont
pas pris une ride
[Musique]
et